turkey wants to be powerful it wants to
revive its national pride flags are a
common sight as are the images of two
men Kemal atatürk he is modern Turkey's
first president and he represents a
secular republic and then of course
there is the image of the current
president Recep Tayyip erawan now he
wants to be the father of a new Turkish
identity one shaped by religious faith
however Turkey remains deeply divided
over what should dominate secularism or
religion
unlike Ataturk Ardoin is putting Islam
first he believes that religion ties the
country together that message is well
received in the pious rural population
they adore Ardoin for allowing people to
wear hats scarves in government offices
and schools something that was
restricted in the past but Erin's
critics say that he has misused last
year's failed coup attempt to boost
Islamic nationalism what does that mean
in practice I'm about to meet a young a
kay party member in this mosque it's new
and financed by the government Muhammad
says that it represents what Edwyn calls
the new Turkey turkey is self-confidence
for a while we got used to losing but
now we know that we can win again we can
be strong and be a great nation because
that's what we were in the past our don
supporters crushed the coup attempt and
they see their victory as an opportunity
to create a new nation they're basing
their newfound power on Islam his fate
is tied to politics and religion it was
like that in the past and it's like that
now the separation of religion and state
does not exist
that's a secularist concept and that
seems outdated now muhammad became a
member of erred once a kay party just a
few years ago after the wave of mass
civil unrest centered around istanbul
skeezy Park they make you do okay when I
on the protests I understood that there
are people who do not want air21 as a
leader in Turkey instead of being with
them I have chosen to be on the side of
my president he believes Turkey is under
attack but Mohammed is not only
religious and an ardent supporter he's
also a lawyer so how does that influence
his decisions he tells me outside the
mosque over a cup of chai coalition coup
attempt has made being a lawyer in this
country difficult that's because it's
hard to give people the feeling that
justice is being carried out properly we
don't know who is connected to terror
organizations Hamas says that his
independence as a lawyer is important
but the during the current state of
emergency people should be on the side
of the government and the nation that
for him is what a real Turk would do
nationalism has always existed in Turkey
even during Ataturk secularism what's
different today I'm eating fatty Ashla a
professor of nationalism studies
nationalism is more dangerous than
secular nationalism it's much more
hostile and polarizing and it divides
the country Edwyn makes promises that we
build our national brands produce planes
ships and national cars and he brings
out the primitive form of nationalism
inside the people party sighs it's only
a matter of time before he loses his job
or even ends up in jail like many of his
colleagues as a result of speaking out
against air Dohan he says the situation
has to change meanwhile more mosques are
being built our advanced blend of Islam
and nationalism is embraced by half of
the population for them it's the path
back to old glories and pre Ataturk
ottoman times